well how many kids dream of growing up
to be a rock star here in Vegas one
person who made that dream come true is
now helping kids here in the valley
discover a path to musical success
a local musician who's been a rock star
for decades
now looking to lift up the next
generation of artists
Brendan Yuri front man of Panic at the
Disco helped to launch Notes for notes a
music studio within a Boys and Girls
Club here in town it's this Hidden Gem
but that's what we're really hoping to
do is expose the opportunity to more
kids so that we can really spark that
interest
[Music]
different things to find their passion
from
drum exercises to freestyle rap
to music production
but it's only Max Hills really exciting
because I know there are people here who
love to do songwriting and who love to
perform just as much as I do it's
overwhelming honestly because there will
be times when I come into like write
something and I don't know where to
start because there's simply so much I
could do just sing by yourself Beyond a
rock star in state of the art studio the
most important aspect is the trained
musical educator on hand to consistently
work with the kids
[Music]
the best part is when you see a kid's
eyes light up and it clicks this is what
I want to do this is who I am and this
is what I'm going to work on and develop
and become
okay
having music education or having someone
who knows about music education to do
that can really help like cut that
process in half I definitely want to
continue pushing myself to become a
better musician but while I'm here I
think it's important to pick up on the
studio and production aspects of music
and the business side of music is not
avoided it's highlighted we take kids
that are already talented like this and
then equip them with the business of
music education so they know how to
publish their songs they know how to
Market it they know how to Brand
themselves I love to write songs I love
to perform I love to sing and so being
in that business would be my ultimate
wish
students in music programs test higher
improve in reading and math and
graduating greater numbers maybe most
notable the emotional growth music to me
it's it's a way to express myself it's
been great for emotional Wellness this
and a lot of therapy because songwriting
itself is just expression they get to
pour out their hearts
look you can do this just try don't
worry about failure just try and I think
that's the real key
foreign